I had no idea you wrote co-wrote one of
my favorite songs Electric Blue by
Icehouse
it's a good one yeah electric blue you
know that song Ryan
um on my knees Tim I'm sorry I don't
have to sing it to you you know the song
You know the song yeah I'll tell you
yeah you want to hear a story about it
please you got me going now so all right
um I I met I ran into Iva Davies who's
the lead lead singer and Lead person
basically in the group ice house uh I
ran into him at a hotel in New York City
that we're both staying in
um and you know I knew ice house I was a
fan of the band and uh we started
talking and I was kind of in a little
bit of downtime I wasn't really working
too much at the moment and he said hey
would you ever want to come to Australia
and you know maybe we could write
something and I said oh I love Australia
let's let's do it so he brought me to
Sydney and um we you know we hung out
and we were there you know and I was
only going to be there for about you
know a week five days and we were we
were messing around and things weren't
clicking and it was kind of like yeah
you know I was getting a little nervous
because you know he brought me all the
way down there and I felt like I was you
know I wasn't delivering in a sense
um and he was just he was the beginning
of when people were just starting
windsurfing and so he was like into
windsurfing and we were both frustrated
he said ah come on let's just go to the
beach man I'll clear our heads or
whatever and he goes I'm gonna go wind
surfing you can go hang out on the beach
so yeah great so we'll go to the beach
and I don't know if you recall but back
in those days and all the beaches were
topless in in Australia
um and so I was sitting on the beach he
was out there windsurfing and I was and
so I'm sitting there and this gal comes
walking up toward me and she's topless
but she had these incredibly blue eyes I
was trying my best just to look at her
eyes at her face to keep my eyes focused
on her or her face and it just popped
into my head
electric glue I went oh okay and then
when we went back to the studio
afterwards I said look I got this idea
and I said I told him he laughed you
know and I said I said let's write up a
song about this girl's eyes that just
penetrate you you know and uh and that
was it we wrote we wrote it in like two
hours